On June 21st 1964 during what was called
the Freedom Summer three civil rights
workers were murdered in Philadelphia
Mississippi by the Ku Klux Klan next a
series of white house telephone
conversations between President Lyndon
Baines Johnson and FBI director J Edgar
Hoover about the murdered civil rights
workers it's 50 minutes as part of
c-span's coverage of the edgar ray
killin trial for the 1964 killings of
three civil rights workers in
Mississippi next we'll look back at
phone calls about the case between
President Lyndon Johnson and FBI
director J Edgar Hoover President
Johnson recorded these calls from June
through August of 1964 from the time
just after the three workers were first
reported missing to the discovery of
their bodies after a 44 day search
we begin with a call from FBI director
Hoover to President Johnson on June 23rd
1964 at 4:05 p.m. two days after the
disappearance of the three civil rights
workers James Chaney Andrew Goodman and
Michael Schwerner here mr. Hoover tells
LBJ the men's car has been found there
are mentions of White House civil rights
council Lee white and deputy attorney
general Nicholas katzenback
on the car Philadelphia an assumption
that probably they were burned in the
car on the other end they have been
taken out and killed on the outside
that kind and
yeah
I think he would be alright
ai-ai-ai-aight don't like to have you
with having to see these people because
we're gonna have more pieces like this
being politically minded they'll want
you to see them now they've seen
katzenback as I understand over here it
might be wise that you've been in
communication with some other wall
misstatement situations this morning I
wouldn't give the details of a number of
agents that we've got you said it was
substantially augmented they get the
entirely sufficient to being kept
advised of any progress that is being
made
at 5:35 p.m. on June 23rd President
Johnson calls FBI director J Edgar
Hoover again topics in this call include
a planned n-double-a-cp protest outside
the White House and an update on the
disappearance of the civil rights
workers in Mississippi which has been
cooperating which had on a three point
alarm to do locate the car so in order
to terminate that we locate any
footprints or any may be in the on the
side of the road the persons who took
the car there
what can I tell the parent I think you
can tell the parents of a that the car
has been found and that is
and that the agents of proceeding was
intensive investigation to determine any
evidence that would aid and the car has
been found and it's been it's been
burned they proceed with intensive
investigation to find out the to to find
the the the perpetrators of the crime
find a perfect indication and the car
yet there is no indication as to whether
they are because the entire inside of
the car is melted into molten metal but
wouldn't there be some bones area we
have sent the laboratory experts there
to make examination of the ashes and of
the inside to see whether there's any
human bones or human human evidence of
ashes that was able to determine whether
the bodies were in the car we will
probably get word on that sometime this
evening
there you are sure though that you have
found the car yes we found the car in
that it is the same make the same color
and the same license numbers that were
on the car when the car was in
Philadelphia Mississippi yesterday
feynman car same make same license
numbers same color and everything yes
all right now
or was it founders from Philadelphia it
was found about I think it was on
highway on state highway 21 which is
Northeast Philadelphia about 8 miles
northeast to Philadelphia state highway
21 eight miles northeast of Philadelphia
but it was not headed toward Meridian no
it was not headed toward batad Meridian
was in the opposite direction of
Meridian I talked to Mississippi they
told me that they had an announcement
that the car and the people in it were
missing prior to their arrival and
Philadelphia and that when they were
later arrived and they were jailed then
that this announcement been made before
that do you know whether that's true or
not that though that couldn't have been
true put in the Dhruva clause this car
was burning yesterday now are you in
touch with all a local official yes are
they cooperating whether they are
cooperating thoroughly this from the
Mississippi Highway Patrol and we have
just trying to locate the car that's
probably no longer necessary now but
cooperative thoroughly what's going to
complicate the picture is there's going
down there some of these agitators of
the movement to investigate this matter
themselves Palmer is flying down to
Philadelphia Mississippi and the I think
she's the wife of a congressman from
Illinois she's a lawyer she's going down
there also
right in those little towns it's there's
gonna be more disturbance but the Irish
are orders to our men that they're
though to allow no one to come within
the boundary of the roped-off area in
which we were working I wonder if your
last one of your best people to
communicate to the governor and suggest
maybe that he'd make a statement that's
a pretty strong statement that he's what
he's gonna do so that we can be sure
that he gives us all the protection we
can I think it'd be a very good idea see
if one of your men won't can't talk to
him and now indicate that I'll take care
of that right away I can keep me
informed
now the first thing you hear at 6:15
p.m. on June 23rd FBI director Hoover
calls President Johnson the recording of
this call starts with mr. Hoover
updating LBJ on the car of the missing
civil rights workers they also discuss
actions by Democratic governor Paul
Johnson of Mississippi before we can
then that we can surround the area to
keep away
and all that type of individual that
will cause us a trouble but we want to
preserve our any footprints or any tire
prints a person who might have come
there with this paw and then left the
car there as they set it afire obviously
whoever did it I didn't back away hours
are hard imagine except to get into
another car and drive away so therefore
we're trying to preserve whatever
evidence we can find on the outside
there but they're so far as one of the
bodies were in the car not we we can't
say that definitely yes or no we can say
it is the car and it is and the license
numbers that will on the car in
Philadelphia Mississippi for the license
numbers on this burn car because the
burning of the car occurred inside the
outside it was not burned the sports
apartment burned but was not destroyed I
conveyed your suggestion that we get in
touch with the governor and see whether
he would issue a state but he could not
be reached for 20 minutes of course he
was hauling a proper I would surmise
that that may be dealing with this
particular thing because the Mississippi
Highway Patrol told us that they had a
flash at the car and they were sending
some of their men down the word was in
order to be of any assistance that they
could both a federal and a state
violation of law I told him I wrote to
still keep after the governor and then
to let me know what the governor was
what the governor said if it was if he
was dealing with this subject what he
said in his tough topics I suggested to
them that they tell the governor that
day it might be desirable for he didn't
they indicate that not only with the
full facilities of the law enforcement
agencies as a Mississippi be extended to
the federal authorities but he would see
that is that everything was done to
bring the perpetrators of this crime to
justice
I don't know much about you call me when
you get in I will yeah another call on
June 23rd 1964 between the FBI director
and President Johnson takes place at
7:15 in the evening topics in this
conversation about the missing civil
rights workers include a statement by
Mississippi Governor Paul Johnson and
assistance offered by the Defense
Department
No into the laboratory and then tomorrow
morning I get if they call you tonight
in the morning you call thank you thank
you
FBI director J Edgar Hoover gives
President Johnson an update on the
investigation into the disappearance of
the civil rights workers in Mississippi
when the two talk at 5:30 p.m. on June
24th 1964 the conversation is
interrupted by LBJ taking another call
the president then gets back to mr.
Hoover there are mentions here of former
CIA director Allen Dulles deke DeLoach
the FBI's liaison to the White House and
Democratic Senator James Eastland of
Mississippi now LBJ and director Hoover
one is that this may have been done by
these three fellows has in order to
create an incident that would inflame
the situation
setting this car fire within sight of a
highway bill only a few feet off the
highway and brand burning it leaving the
license tags on the car was another
thing a person would do who probably had
committed a murder and that killed the
three but that the three fellows may
have done it themselves and they've been
several reports which were running out
down there but two into two white man
resembling these two fellows two of
these three fellows who were seen at an
airport trying to board a plane going
west to the los angeles that of course
is one of these cases where people the
thing that we lead strongly to here that
these three may have another call I'll
call him right back i Walter told me the
dicas upset something because it's
somebody and indicated that Dulles was
supposed to go down there and be an
investigator and I told him to never had
that farthest thing from my mind what
happened was after we talked yesterday
you got the governor to have that press
conference he gave out a wonderful
statement and he called Jim Eastland it
was my friend and your friend and told
Eastland that he would like for me to
see some of the problems that they were
confronted rode down here with all these
damn fellows parading all over the place
and that he
he would like for me to send an
impartial observer to come and talk to
him and he would like to see send him to
talk to few of the businessman and try
to see how we could avoid some of this I
think what he's gonna order Dulles to do
is to explain to folks here what's
happening to their state that everybody
coming into it so I tried to figure out
somebody that I could send to get to go
down there and so I finally decided this
I get this boy with Mulroney in Dulles
and I got to I got him on the phone and
he said he'd go 1 so they asked him what
if he's going down there take over
investigation and he said hey you want
to make it an investigative any kind if
they're already competent best get his
own spot he's born my personal and boy
to get two views of the governor and
other leaders Mississippi now I tell
like if the governor asked me to send an
impartial observer and I didn't send it
up being a little bad shape to do
something I if I had a thought for one
moment that is something that would
affect you in any way I picked up phone
called you because I've got a better
friend this government in Iran that I
always will have and so I told him to
find a question in my press conference
and George Reedy told him where to head
in yes
well I'm gonna stop by to see me this
morning and he told me that he had
several inquired paragraphs as to
whether he was going to take over the
investigation nobody will take away
anything from me as long as I live it
made it very clear that he was
definitely there
to confer with the governor and to see
that what the general atmosphere was
well I felt a little red last night
there is out of my time might be asked
can you do a little too much but I have
to get somebody to do it in
and when you got him to make that
statement that's the best thing that's
happened to us and if you just repeat
that over there so it'll help you say
right he's been very decent with us
we've gotten along fine with him and I
told Ellen jealous that his Alan asked
me whether he might quote me to the
governor as what I had to say about the
Mississippi Highway Patrol and about the
attitude of the governor on any court
that's good well nobody's ever gonna
take anything between us sure that we
make a mistake of ahead sometimes I'll
make a lot of over here every day today
as you just tell thee to what score and
we'll get it straight not so damn quick
to make your head Swamy don't nobody
gonna take our 30-year friendship and
mess it up one bit
President Johnson calls FBI director J
Edgar Hoover at 4:18 p.m. on June 25th
1964 mr. Hoover tells LBJ about his
talks with the governor of Mississippi
they also discussed the search for the
missing men and if not you're gonna get
we're not going to get the Marines at
all what's happened on that thing they
had told us down that Meridian that this
face outside of there was a Marine base
and we were we made the request of the
the Defense Department form of the
access to have those Marines assist in
the search meantime your knee trust
statement came out saying Marines were
going to be used and so the Defense
Department being strictness four
protocols understood that to be an order
for Marines and therefore ordered
Marines in from Camp Lejeune I I got in
touch with him as soon as I got this
word from Walla Walla Jenkins I'm not
the concern of Johnson and he was the
Defense Department said that they had
read this statement of yours and
therefore they'd have to send the
Marines ins and could use the word Murry
unless it was automatic I said I'll take
the responsibility for automatic they
had one plane already in the air enroute
to meridian with Marines from Camp
Lejeune I said send that plane back to
Camp Lejeune and keep the Marines at
Camp Lejeune what we want all the our
men is manpower and these Navy men that
our at Meridian will use them so that
present straightened out and out there
that has been done so we've got now 200
nearly personnel at the Navy base there
and then we've got our own then and look
at the Mississippi Highway Patrol I
explained all that to the governor and
he's thoroughly satisfied with it yeah
he said the National Guard was entirely
available and it would be subject to our
calls we wanted them I said we had given
some thought to that this morning very
frankly we thought that it would be
better to use the local military people
the naval people there at Meridian
because the National Guard are all
natives of the state and it's not
integrated and the extremists of the
Negro moon would will begin to holla
that we had brought the anti-negro
National Guard into this picture to make
the search I said they claimed the FBI
is and integral also but I said in order
not to add any more fuel to the fire I
said we decided to use a local naval
personnel and I said they are the ones
that are now going to be used are no
Marines coming into Mississippi the
sailors will be under our direction
they're married to make the switch
he said that was fine and I said I'll
see that in the future if there's
anything that develops that the
statements going to be made on that
because of any significance I called you
all have our man down they'd be in touch
with you the source to alert you so
you'll be informed he said that would be
fine he wanted us to still know that he
wanted to extend full cooperation etc
and I calls
and explain the same thing day in and he
was thoroughly satisfied he said that
after him to make some kind of a press
statement and I told him I said well you
could make a press statement to the
effect that I have said as I told Island
Ellis yesterday and he could tell the
governor that the governor has been most
cooperative and the Mississippi Highway
Patrol in the in this case say on TV
afternoon this Marine base outside of
Meridian that's what is it a naval base
it's a naval base
yes and then when we cut clearance
appear to call on that to call on them
for personnel meantime your statement
came out mentioning the word Marines and
what you told me yes that's what I told
you that's what I said over in the
memorandum and the Defense Department
saying it said since you used the word
Marines then they would have to bring
Marines in well we can guess we got it
corrected with the press so I think the
thing we ought to say is that we were
notified from local authorities that
that's personnel near Meridian that a
naval installation and there's
we find that they're gonna use Navy boys
instead of marine boy that's what they
have that that's correct
okay that's correct President Johnson
calls FBI director J Edgar Hoover at
1:17 p.m. on June 26th 1964 during this
portion of their conversation they
discussed the search for the missing
civil rights workers as well as the
situation in Mississippi where racial
unrest and the number of civil rights
demonstrators are increasing
a number of people down there and I
think God sent some more and if for no
other reason to say to these groups that
oppression is all time that we have
reviewed it several weeks ago on the top
being you sent in people anticipating it
you sent in more following these three
dollars and down you're gonna send in
some more so that we can let those
people know it we mean business may we
can prevent some of these acts of terror
by the very presence of people I'm
hoping that this case that they've
developed down at this place called
teeny-weeny the pain that but I'm hoping
it that if we can get the department
we're gonna submit it to them this
afternoon to authorize us to arrest
those on them that will be a deterrent
because they told these two white boys
if you don't get out of town the same
things going to happen to you is
happening up at then pull it up here
well you just go on about air test back
but not sure partner give you the
authority that you consider sending some
other people down there so we can say we
supplement it following this report and
the more you have their they more
they're gonna prevent things not all
send troops in there Marshall - I'd
rather you send another 15 40 people
all right he's gonna talk to National
Council of Churches mister Allah said
yeah so that word will get around
I've already also just a flat formatter
there gets their planning up large
picketing of you at that cuckoo Hall and
Detroit this evening starting at four pm
and to demand that President Johnson
sentence federal marshals Mississippi to
protect civil rights workers we notified
the Secret Service of that they will
have the necessary on July 2nd 1964
President Johnson talks to FBI director
Jo Hoover shortly after 5:00 p.m.
LBJ is in the executive mansion the
living quarters of the White House the
recording of this call starts with mr.
Hoover's news about the missing civil
rights workers with mention of the
family of one of the young men mr.
Hoover and the president also discuss
whether federal troops should be sent to
Mississippi and past Ku Klux Klan
activity in Texas LBJ refers to the
Civil Rights Act which he will sign
later that evening and within where they
have him
they have hitting away and he refuses to
tell off the nickname of the grandmother
which I think pretty clearly shows about
the fate we're running that down along
the grounds extortion that's a violation
of the extortionist actions so far as
the Mississippi equation is concerned
I've got a copper thorn and Jackson's
afternoon for a matter of space we've
located space down a path there's a
question whether he concerned that owns
the building will rent to an integrated
agency because we're integrated in the
FBI we have Negro agents all the way up
there in Mississippi per se but that'll
be within the course of the next hour
and then it'll take us to possibly maybe
a couple of weeks building make
arrangements for the formal opening of
the office and in line with the
conversation this morning we can
reevaluate the need of my going down
there I'm perfectly willing to do so I
think there are several aspects of that
we want to keep in mind first whether
these racist war yell that we waited to
this these three people have disappeared
and then tried to plug the gap but
suddenly opening an awl and officer
Jackson but the answer in my mind
anything of that kind is that whatever
you do you're going to be damned can't
satisfy both sides now I have this do I
have this deal ain't nobody got damn you
there's a feeling I have you didn't
create this situation you didn't have
anything to do it FBI didn't have
anything do it they nobody but a few
comments acute crackpots a few our
people are against you in this country
there you know
is anybody in countries doctor expect
you have what I think the order to order
I just want you to consider it and
evaluate it and how they got your
judgment because so just curtains good
you don't have to be blustering a
threatening you're dignified in Quad and
modest on bullying but you have a
perfect right to peer at your office and
you have been called on for
extraordinary I think your give serious
thought next day or two I may be going
if not I'll talk to you Saturday this is
Thursday see how many people you can
bring in Monday until we find this
answer I think the best your foot 1500
people after this plan and studying this
from one County the other I think their
very presence may save us a division of
soldiers not not throwing their weight
around there so under pistols that you
don't hear you don't hear criticism of
any of your people but if they are there
I think you ought to have the best
intelligent system better than you got
on the Communists I read it doesn't hear
reports last night here to one o'clock
on communists and there they came to
open their mouth without you knowing
what they're saying now I don't want
these plans in the open their mouth
without your knowing what you're saying
I nobody needs to know it but you may be
but we ought to have intelligence on
that state toes that's gonna be the most
dangerous thing we have this year I
think I think if I have to send in
troops or somebody gets raised they have
to go like what they did in the Little
Rock or or something else it could be
off too dangerous now nobody objects the
FBI everybody there all the local people
nobody really objects to the Navy boys
that was a masterstroke when you got
down but I'm having these demands for
5,000 soldiers
and all these groups are meeting all
over the United States
sending wires farmers got a group out
Kansas City today they called up
yesterday Martin Luther King's getting
ready to all this so the only way I can
answer them yesterday now I have
substantial people in every area this
state we are carefully studying this
thing we carefully investigate me and to
send in a bunch of marshals are sending
that have no law to enforce that nothing
been violated or send in a bunch of army
people divisions it's just a mistake but
I've got ample FBI people and I would I
would express the hope even if I have to
get a supplemental appropriation for you
that you figure out where you can borrow
him and case for an emergency and let's
put them in there for the next 3040 days
while we while we're making this search
and until this thing Cotton's down a
little bit but we will certainly work
that out now you make an estimate call
your district manner whoever you need to
and let me talk to you day after
tomorrow and see how many we can put in
there next week and my idea was if I
went down there cooperating you're
getting you getting a voluntarily after
we talk to governor and you had him have
that first press conference that's funny
broke your eyes you're getting
voluntarily what you try to get with a
battalion of Marines exactly without
still attached right now what I want you
to do though I want you to put in 50 100
men and scare them I want you to have
the same kind of intelligence you have
on the college now this plan could
spread all through the 11 southern
states and and be off I know but I mean
it could be you remember they're
electing senators in Texas in 1924
Mayfield came up here and we've just got
to see because that object be flogging
people and be violating this statute
goes into effect I'm gonna sign it it's
6:45 tonight yeah I'm gonna make
television statement and yeah
and I want to then if this thing blows
up I want to be in a position of saying
I put all the people down from the
searching detail and get them into this
plan side which when you consider where
are you gonna forget 1500 send in there
too so we can say we sent three bunches
on July 13th 1964 President Johnson is
in the living quarters of the White
House when he calls FBI director J Edgar
Hoover at 3:30 4:00 p.m.
LBJ asks mr. Hoover about reports that
bodies have been found in Mississippi
they also discussed the directors recent
trip to that state there's mention of
civil rights activist Medgar Evers who
was shot to death in Mississippi in June
1963 by a white supremacist somebody
told me television that erupted instead
they found another body
identifying the morning
like you said over here one of the best
things I think it's happening is your
trip I would like for you to say in that
memorandum for my years that you down
over your office you have called on
following people and that you said to
the governor and the governor said to
you yes
that would show or rather
polite and reasonable reaction from both
the federal and the state affairs and
give me over copy of it means and it I
don't like I'd like to I soft with new
place I'd for these big people that
wanted to cap it man this morning and
one or two that are pretty for the
influential and how I think that has
been held in bounds largely because you
don't that just rich I got to give out
that first interview remember back
anyone in and I think you got in got out
without being high-handed without
getting without getting announced yeah I
would like to try to imply the rest of
us do like why yeah well I it's the
thing that I think it's so important if
you just say met dermis press percent to
your request here
a limo on my trip left here in I arrived
I want to see the job and I spent 50
minutes living when I talked until about
number of man I had what I was trying to
do and I asked him to give me all the
help he could I thank him for the hand
it over
I thought I would take five members of
the Highway Patrol we want to get more
of his men trained by the FBI that's put
that in there I will I want to show I
thank you we've got to lean over
backwards to two
that's why they do that in this memo
show me that you office told him it's
you're gonna be investigating everything
it was a federal violation civil rights
camera and everything else and that he
offered cooperation in your works down
and you have reason to believe that he's
trying to do the best he can and he
needs to train people are you going to
help train them and you're gonna work
with him any way you can you're going to
keep right on it you got your office
there now and anybody was cutting the
complaint on anything it needs
investigating from La Jolla California
FBI director J Edgar Hoover calls
President Johnson at 4:36 p.m. August
5th 1964 the president reacts to the
news that the bodies of the three civil
rights workers have been found in
Mississippi and mr. Hoover gives LBJ an
update on the investigation
and there were some another man so we
have all those names that we're
concentrating now on developing the
evidence you could want to call a grand
jury in the possible in its two weeks at
consenting the burning of the church and
bring before the grand jury the
particular 10 man and hoping that one of
them may then break but I think it's
gonna be able to seen that one up the
one in charger is making very good
progress I've been in touch with the
boys down there I think we're gonna have
that one cleared up we know who was
participated in that also
it's the plan in both places but I think
we'll be able to make a stable report on
cases just start did he get damn tired
of it and then come and see me to get
back by you lunch on August 8th the
LBJ's at the ranch in Stonewall Texas
when he calls the FBI director about
10:00 a.m. the president reads a
statement he'll release about the
murders of the civil rights workers in
Mississippi mr. Hoover makes suggestions
statement press conference more now on
to go over trillion seek any suggestion
this morning I thought the chair Hoover
he assured me that the investigation
Mississippi is going well and that sub
Spence substantive the results can be
expected in a short period of time
murder in any state whether Mississippi
Georgia New York and civil disorder in
any region north or south east or west
cannot and will not be condoned in this
country we must not allow violence and
lawlessness to go unpunished
no person can be allowed to attack the
right of every American to be secure in
this land under our system of government
local authorities have the basic
responsibility for several piece we look
to the governor's the local officials to
keep today's and protect the citizen is
essential to our federal system that
they keep that responsibility and
federal police force is inconsistent
with the tradition of this country and I
did not believe when miscreants such
enforced keeps beasts enforce the laws
but inaction on the part of government
when federal laws or violation
assistance is needed is equally
repugnant to our tradition we intend to
do our part when it is necessary and
right to do so I think that's excellent
but I want to congratulate you on way in
Georgia I see why they look like they
got some guy in Chicago trying to handle
little money around sure want to stay on
their tail okay you've been listening to
phone calls between President Lyndon
Johnson and FBI director J Edgar Hoover
on the 1964 murders of three civil
rights workers in Mississippi the calls
are part of over 450 hours of phone
conversations made available to the
public by the Lyndon Johnson Library in
Austin Texas c-span radio airs more of
the LBJ phone calls every Saturday at
3:00 p.m. Eastern Time and replayed
Tuesday nights at 10:00 Eastern Time
c-span radio can be heard in the
Washington Baltimore region at 90.1 FM
across the country on XM satellite radio
channel 132 and sirius satellite radio
channel 113 and on the web at c-span
radio dot org